just kidding news careful boys is a
brand just kidding news is the man of
smart people the people of just kidding
news careful boys they are very smart
just kidding news the number one forcast
in the
[Music]
world so this is a funny statement but
I'm sure it'll lead into a very
intellectual discussion here on JK uh
there's a GOP congressman who has
claimed that the Bible has been banned
in America for 60 years right rep
Burgess Owen it's that all the [__]
hotels what are you talking
about you're right you're right did you
know that the hotels don't do that it's
a crew they're like a the B they're like
a Bible crew yeah it's a Bible crew and
plant them in hotels no there's a name
like you yeah they literally the Bible
Brigade The Bible
Brigade it's the name of their crew is
actually on that Bible I forgot the name
of it but but when you open it up Bible
Brigade it's the Bible
Brigade we're actually a Christian they
leave it in every single [__] drawer
they just they just go and I was like
they physically do it themselves in
every I don't know about that I like to
believe that they do like they check
into every room I don't know that's a
lot of money that a lot of money it's a
lot of paper a lot of leather were smart
they would just wait to see the
housekeeping girls just leave the room
for a second I didn't think that
through but I would it was because it's
written on the Bible this was placed by
Bible Brigade Bible Brigade Bible
Brigade did and I was reading that like
oh work so well I have to say it slow
too cuz I almost want to say
barbell I haven't seen it these days not
like when I used to all the time
pandemic shut him down yeah took him out
of business what it is yeah yeah or
maybe you've been going to nicer hotels
they don't have it at the Ritz no really
they don't have Bibles in the rits I
don't they usually have they they have
it at the ones where I think you're
doing the sins at ah okay but I go to
those
too yeah I go to those the crack ones
yeah the
radas the Bibles next to the
Cockroaches the cockroach is actually
reading the Bible John
316 they love John 3:16 bro that's their
favorite so yeah this rep appears to
believe that the Bible has been banned
in the US since 1963 the congressman
made the W claim morning during a house
sub subcommittee on Early Childhood
Elementary and secondary education
hearing about banning explicit content
from school libraries do you guys
remember well I I think the discussion
that is interesting here is I remember
there was once a time where um the
Christians believed that under a
Christian Nation uh our school education
system wasn't getting a fair
representation of like the nation's
values through Christianity because they
were choosing to teach teach like
physical sciences which was like
contradictory specifically to like
Christian core foundations and stuff and
saying that like you know cuz that the
argument was like oh you shouldn't be
putting religion on the kids they're
like well you're putting science on the
kids in in a school curriculum which is
the anti you know what I mean so that
was kind of a conversational argument at
the time so just the idea that we all
grew up with probably a lot more of a
Christian foundational like you know cuz
I even got The Beginner's Bible when I
was a kid too at like a monori and stuff
like that but now I don't know what the
kids are getting like maybe barking
answer like what taica is receiving in
schooling and stuff like that is there a
Christian Nation foundation not at all
like his stuff is just well I also feel
like I don't think I got any Christian
stuff cuz I went to regular public
school and I don't remember any talk of
any religion and then when I went to a
private elementary school that uh was
Christian you had a specific like either
beginning of the day or end of day like
Bible study and then um yeah and so that
was like night and or day difference
like singing hymns and [__] like that
and I remember going back into a public
school and there was no mention of
Christianity at all that was my
experence the Pledge of Allegiance in
the morning right where everybody stood
up and still had under God but that's
not Christian that's the Pledge of
Allegiance still under God but our
dollars say In God We Trust that's what
I'm saying that's what it is yeah
foundational Christian yeah there's like
this this underlying oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah for sure oh like that yeah so at
taica school um that's one thing I was
actually worried about I was like [__] I
don't know if these [__] woke ass
schools like if they're going to be
programming like these kids I went to
one of their uh school plays and in the
beginning of the school play taica did
the Pledge of Allegiance I was like good
good American values keep that up and
then they have their own um they had
their own School Allegiance [__] too it
was like we work hard we play hard and
we always have fun or something like
that I'm oh TI what a disproven guy
[__] I don't want any [__]
5-year-old saying that [__] yeah
inappropriate lame do they not do that
anymore at school the Pledge of
Allegiance all kids think that you're
saying
invisible invisible I don't know I feel
like a lot of the woke ass schools might
have a way different they probably don't
even sing outlook on on school
allegiance to the rainbow
flag funny [__] though if anyone who's
been to like hardcore Christian School
growing up probably had the same thing
cuz by I guess they're required to still
teach science even though like we
believe you know God created us reluct
but it's like rock science they teach
the EV they side comments while they do
it yeah they do it so sarcastically and
like it's so funny our teacher would be
like all right so we're going to cover
the science part now get this guys they
think we came from monkeys and we
evolved like they're so like uh shitty
about it when they say it
it's like it becomes like a standup
thing and everyone's laughing you see
this yeah they call it gravity I call it
God's power dude he's killing our
science teacher is killing I kind of
want to sit through one of those classes
here you have to like learn some a
little more science and every time they
make it like a funny thing and we all
just laugh it's so weird I think it is a
part of the curriculum like the
standardized if you want it to be a
credited school so there's two different
Christian Schools I went to Christian
private school the one that we went to
and another one that I went to with Tim
delto and it's exactly like that you
have to have a science class right and
then they'll kind of say well get this
and then they'll joke about it and I
remember this one teacher she was like
so uh this whole Evolution thing right
where's the missing link like if we came
from monkeys there's no Missing Link
they still can't find it but somehow
they think we come from monkeys yeah
their favorite thing was to say that us
to love that she'll be like like the
teacher will go well what why are
monkeys still around kids why do we
still have them and we're all like kids
we're like I don't know sounds crazy
right you're like six like yeah we're
not
monkeys like you guys are [__] idiots
you guys don't know anything I remember
in preschool uh every year during
Christmas time we would do the Nativity
Play right and I I remember Hela wanted
to be one of the three kings but I ended
up getting the shepherd yeah you're Bal
time yeah just being not happy about it
cuz like my friend would get like the
Kings and they would get come in holding
these like jewelry boxes but I would
just hold a [__] stick you know what
I mean pissed off but I'm I'm thinking
about this growing up and I'm like I
wonder what my parents thought just
growing up Buddhist but like needing to
be a part of this program and singing
[__] Christian hymns and stuff it
seems like are Buddhist people more
chill about that than like my parents
are super chill I feel like Buddhists
are the most chill when it comes to yeah
you can be both like I've never heard of
any other religion where you could be
like yeah you could dabble in whatevers
bro like yeah Buddhism is like well we
don't even got a god it's more like a
way of thinking
dude that's pretty tight I like that I
flip-flop I remember the first time I
went to a Christian School it was like
it was such a culture shock for me and
we I think during the I forgot I think
it was like towards Christmas they gave
everybody like matah bread or something
like that like cuz I think the the story
was like oh this is what they ate during
this time
we say matab BR I just remember being
like what the [__] is this I I was like
it's it's hella random cuz I just and I
didn't when I went to Christian School I
didn't know my parents didn't prep me
for anything they didn't tell me what
the [__] Jesus Christ was I didn't
know anything nck is like praying is
this how you pray yeah no seriously like
okay this how and then they tell us
about we'd have to like learn Jonah and
the whale and the way they'd be talking
about it wasn't like it was a story it
was more of like or like a fable it was
more of like this [__] happened and
during the time I just I couldn't wrap
my head around it I just was like do you
guys really think this guy got swallowed
by a whip you didn't go [__] that's
what happened to Pinocchio not you yeah
just yelling out [__] in class
[__] it's a wooden
boy it's not Jonah it's Pinocchio that's
crazy to get no prep whatsoever no prep
and I just was like okay so Samsonite
had like long hair and it made him
strong I was like what I was like Sam
Samsonite whatever
how old were you huh I was in sixth
grade oh yeah that's a little older to
be shocked into it that's your fault
yeah that's my fault that's your fault
you shouldn't you should have gate
weighed a little bit into Christianity
by then like how you're just ignorant
dude I've always had friends that would
invite me to their Church like growing
up it was just like Youth for Christ
stuff yeah like they'll be like hey you
want to sleep over the weekend I'm like
yeah and then but like but we have to go
to church and I'm like all right and
then so uh you know we already we
already went to church but at the time
there were you know we went to church on
Saturday so I had a double [__]
church but then it was different that's
tough double church but Sunday churches
are way more fun though you know that
was more fun it was why was it more fun
cuz it wasn't Catholic that's why oh
yeah they had the fun [__] cathol
Catholic Church is long bro oh that's
what I grew up in oh yeah yeah Catholic
Church oh the Filipino stuff yeah but my
grandma cooked for the the church oh the
oh that's true we always had food it was
so good dude I went to like
more of like a Catholic based funeral
and then they do they say in Spanish the
whole a a Maria whatever the whole
[__] like they they say that Latin I
don't know that's what it said on the
the pamphlet that they where everyone
says like amen like five times whatever
yeah everyone standing up it's Latino
that [__] takes so [__] long dude
yeah how long does it take oh yeah that
[__] that probably a couple like it's
pretty long if you been to a Buddhist
thing if you been to a Buddhist thing
Buddhist ones are long I don't know but
but when someone passes away they do it
like s days in a row no cuz I I went
with geot toath and they hold all the
beads they hold all the beads and say it
every time and then like and sometimes
when they're in the funeral like you get
a couple people who are like I know my
[__] words everyone else is kind of
saying it quietly but they're kind of
like the one person hell dude they're
spitting their [__] thing holy Mary
Mother of God yeah yeah some some some
yeah bro and you're just sitting in
there like oh my god when does this
[__] stop and it lasts
forever and then they go again and then
my grandma's just there with the rosary
and she's going like this every time we
say one oh man and I didn't know what
they were doing like holding the beads
and then like an hour in I'm like oh
every time she says it she's going down
the beads and there still the other side
and I was like oh [__] this is going to
take forever and we got to come back
tomorrow and the day after it was so
long bro I have friends that when they
have relatives that die they're gone for
like the next several days and they're
just like I got to go they probably
praying because you have to meet up
every day for like however long and then
oh we got to prayer we got prayer you
know damn it's not even like a relative
they close to it's just they just do
that but low keilo the the pondu set
that they give you and the afterwards
it's work there a mar right it kind of
hits bro it hits harder at a funeral
kind of that's what that's what you're
thinking of more salt from the tears
like sad bro it's I was EA these these
these the PES and I was like oh my God
these are Del ious I love funerals and
you're like you said we got to come back
tomorrow too I was like h no and TI was
like shut up stop being so loud about it
I was like compliments to the
shf
[Music]
Bravo
h